[Music]
hile
this is just a small update so if you'd
like to go straight to the video you
should see a time on screen that you can
skip to or alternatively you can find a
timestamp in the description I live in a
small sometimes third-world light
country down on the ass end of the globe
New Zealand we recently lost power at
home following a small storm and it took
almost seven days to get us back on the
grid sadly this happens quite often
ironically it was right after I released
the blackout video I also lived somewhat
rural II so no power means no running
water as well now if you can imagine
this combined with a wife who is now in
a tenth month of pregnancy it hasn't
been a hugely pleasant week or so so why
am I telling you this I informed a large
number of you that the discord server
would be live within a few days it's now
been about two weeks so I apologize for
this things were a little out of my
control but now I can finally say it's
ready and the link will be in the
description going back to the overdue
pregnant wife thing I'm not going to be
hugely available over the next few weeks
for obvious reasons but my man lone
wanderer will be able to sort you out
when you join write a message in the
reception area and he'll be able to hook
you up to the rest of the server I'm not
big on discord I just really haven't put
the time into it so if you have any
questions please message wanderer or any
of the other mods as I said I'm not
going to be hugely available over the
next few weeks but most of you that
messaged me with solar flares after a
team so get in there mingle and start
teaming up I'll be seeing you in there
soon anyway on to the video
let's talk whip and talents with other
50 whip and talents available it's not
as easy as saying which ones are good
and which ones are bad because of the
nature of this game and the vast amount
of build options available some of the
worst talents in the game can still be
useful in the right situation the
following will be based off the more
generic builds or maybe they just have a
wider range of usefulness but don't let
this put you off and trying talents that
aren't on this list here are all of the
width and talents currently available in
the game as of 1.8 firstly will remove
all exotic weapon talents because
there's specific to these weapons only
and can't be rolled off anyway the rest
of the weapon talents can be broken down
into three tiers
1 2 & 3 tier 1 being the most useful and
tier 3 being the least now let's remove
tier 2 & 3 because let's face it if
you're watching this video you want to
know about the best talents but this
doesn't mean that the tier 2 & 3 talents
are completely useless in fact some
niche builds can get some good use out
of them for example on the console I
love using balanced on my sniper builds
it allows me to be considerably more
responsive allowing me to not just hit
targets faster but also be more
effective at medium and even close range
and the combination of talents like
meticulous and commanding can make for a
pretty fun constant tech link solo build
but for the majority of builds these are
certainly not the best use of a weapon
slot basically what I'm trying to say is
don't write off the talents they don't
discuss here they still have their place
but for now we'll focus on the tier 1
weapon talents ferocious damage against
elite and named enemies is increased by
10% destructive armor destruction value
is increased by 15% when using this
weapon these are both top tier PvE
talents but neither are particularly
useful in PvP ferocious has quite
difficult requirements to meet for most
builds so in most situations you'll need
to have this rolled into the third slot
the free slot the third slot on a weapon
doesn't require you to meet the step
requirements also on top of increasing
weapon damage these two skills can also
increase the damage of certain skills
like the B FB sticky bomb and seeker
mines deadly critical hit damage is
increased by 15% depending on the build
and the weapon this is a fairly decent
boost and damage best use would build
spaced around critical hit chance and
damage and with SMGs which have a native
critical hit chance bonus responsive
damage is increased by 10% when closer
than 10 meters to the target useful in
both PvE and PvP but more often than not
this is a PvP talent most pvp fights end
up with agents getting within 10 meters
of each other and PvE getting this close
can often end up with having you quickly
downed by the super-powered NBC melee
but there are certain builds like the d3
fnc which can take advantage of this
prepared damage is increased by 15% when
more than 30 meters from the target
elevated increase your damage by 10%
when elevated more than 1.2 meters
above your target best used with
marksman rifles in fact elevated can
only be rolled onto a specific madman
rifle the m700 personally I find
elevated a little too situational for my
taste but there's a good reason why it's
a top-tier talent and I'll go into that
soon competent
we've been damages increased by 10
percent for 15 seconds after using a
skill this is probably one of my
favourite talents it's best used with
the build that has medium to high skill
haste it works well with skill power
builds because you're constantly
cranking up the skills but it's also
quite useful on a DPS build with skills
like pulse and booster shot both of
these skills are assisting your builds
with extra damage and competent we'll be
adding a further 10% damage every time
you use them area unforgiving missing
health segments increase your damage one
missing segment plus 10% to missing
segments plus 25% top-tier talent in PvP
but it can still be useful in PvE
the burst damage this can give when
facing an enemy agent can really turn
the fight in your favor but in PvE you
can be a little bit risky to allow your
health to get this low certain builds
like the d3 if NC or nomads could find
this useful but more often than not
there's a bit of talent to go for
predatory killing a target regenerates
35% health over 20 seconds hands down
one of the best PvE talents in the game
it doesn't add to your damage output but
it'll help keep you alive I don't have a
single PvE build that doesn't take
advantage of this talent because of the
high stamina requirement this may need
to be rolled into the third slot
determined killing a target reduces
skill cooldowns by 7.5 percent black
predatory determined isn't going to
increase your damage numbers in any way
but the skill cooldown makes it a great
addition to any skill power built but it
isn't just skills that it'll help with
it'll also reduce signature skill
cooldowns so for example when
considering how important the recovery
link is to solo players essentially
becoming an extra life this can be quite
useful to a number of different build
types because of the unusual step
requirements this usually needs to be
rolled into the third slot talented
killing a target with this weapon
increases your skill power by 15% for 20
seconds another great skill power build
weapon talent because a lot of skill
power builds are quite squishy I mean
they usually glass cannons in their own
right you really need to get as
damaged your utility is possible out of
your skills to make up for this with the
right belt this will help get
considerably more damage or
effectiveness out of your skills when it
comes down to getting the absolute best
damage out of your bill there's another
step you need to consider
we've been talents calculate their bonus
damage and either a multiplicative or
additive way basically multiplicative as
the name suggests means that damage
types are multiplied together we're
additive damage types are added
multiplicative will give you more damage
over one talento may not be a heck of a
lot but over four or five talents the
numbers really start to show so which
weapon talents are multiplicative and
which are additive well apart from the
following which are always
multiplicative responsive prepared and
elevated the risk come down to the
damage type that they're adding for
example ferocious adds 10% damage to
elites and destructive adds 15% enemy
armor damage these are two different
damage types and combined the in damages
calculated multiplicatively we're
destructive with another enemy armor
damage piece would be calculated
additively this probably doesn't make a
huge amount of sense right now and I'd
love to go into more detail but instead
when you're ready I recommend checking
out a video from Marko style released at
the end of last year he does a brilliant
job explaining the difference between
additive and multiplicative damage types
and how to get the absolute best damage
out of your builds I'll post a link in
the description I definitely recommend
checking this out when you have a chance
sometimes as your build that decides
what talents you can use for example if
you are running a firearms heavy build
you'll only be able to unlock talents
that require high firearms like deadly
and responsive but this is where the
third slot talent comes in the free slot
this is where you can activate talents
that would otherwise be unavailable to
your build giving you greater
flexibility and diversity within the
whip and talent vault so with this in
mind and the fact you can re-roll one of
the talents on your weapon you need to
look at where the talents are located
for example let's say you find a
lightweight in fall with the talents
determined ferocious and destructive in
the third slot although these are all
top tier talents the slot location makes
us a feely
Everage weapon
destructive is already quite an easy
talent to unlock so it's a bit of a
waste being in the third slot we're
determined in ferocious have more
difficult requirements to unlock and in
most cases you'll find that one or both
of these talents will be unavailable to
your built I'll leave you with some good
whip and talent examples now these are
based off the typical DPS build
sustainability and skill power build
please don't take these is the single
best and only option this is just a
starting point to give you an idea based
on the information stated earlier anyway
I hope you found this useful
there is certainly a lot more depth we
could go into but for now I think this
is a good start if you need a little
more information on anything just let me
know in the comments and I'll try and
get back to you
Cheers
[Music]